what is this what is this the try not to
get satisfied you think I can't get
satisfied well then bring it on no
that's not what I meant damn oh alright
here we go you can play along see if you
do the goal is to not get satisfied now
I haven't seen anyone else do this I
have no idea if it [ __ ] works but
let's just give it a go I know I don't
feel satisfied what the [ __ ] is this oh
yeah yeah yeah through the mirror this
is cringe oh how is this satisfying
Danny
[Music]
oh just pull it up just ball it up
now stop stop just stop stop it
get some help I poured glue all over my
hand let it dry and had an amusing time
peeling it off well how about you just
go and play overwatch and said how about
that [ __ ] next one water hole in
portico how is this supposed to be
satisfied
[Music]
ambient music and the artsy drone shot
is not gonna do it thank you very much
[Music]
where is the satisfaction I need at
least a penis or a hole
I need something long or something holy
I need something long and stiff or a
big-ass hole otherwise there will be no
stimulation I'm 12 shut up
whoa whoa whoa is that real nah hell nah
there's no way that's real is that real
what oh no I'm not satisfied I'm just
amazed it's that it's that mother
nature's butthole stop it that is
[ __ ] cool man
that is really cool not satisfying not
satisfied I am yet to fail this one
challenge cranber-- Alea another one I
don't I think it's kind of gross I don't
like creme brulee so maybe that's like
my issue you know this is my jam I never
watches before
but let's see if I can keep up somebody
was so leave it well is 850
I think I did pretty good
[ __ ] what is this beat ha that's holes
how is hole oh that's disgusting
how is holes satisfying someone explain
that to me
nevermind I'll try not to get disgusting
challenge this is what this is Danny
DeVito bless your soul yeah yeah yeah
okay why is this is interesting to me
because it seems like the line between
satisfying and disgusting is very close
because surely some people find this
satisfying to watch while others just
grossed out he draw like right okay
those are pretty satisfying so this
might be it
instead of raw it's a rubber band that's
gonna be cool I just imagine my head
being crushed underneath
maybe only okay
Oh Oh
keep pressing come on I want it to
explode that's it baby
oh it's happening it's happening
yeah yeah looks like a finger what the
[ __ ] is their real body in there that
looks like a testicle
[ __ ] I thought I would be satisfied I
want to be satisfied daddy
ha don't you like me anymore oh yeah
but they're fine
[Music]
[ __ ] say hey hey it's [ __ ]
squirted Jesus I don't I don't think
it's satisfying I don't think it's
satisfying okay I don't know I can't I
can't explain why all right
maybe you think so I am not satisfied
what is its custom falcon rests in pain
pen oh that's pretty cool how it splits
oh that's cool oh that's pretty cool
it's a [ __ ] pen
hi pride bro ice cream
the [ __ ] assists
that's pretty cool
yeah that's pretty that's pretty that's
pretty that's pretty cool
Wow no it's not [ __ ] satisfying get
out of here
slime in the world yeah yeah stop it's
not stop all the sound oh it reminds me
what the [ __ ] the most satisfying video
in the world must see okay I'm glad cuz
I can really see it wow I'm really
enjoying this video oh wow what a great
video see this [ __ ] this satisfied
watching precise pristine
high high end machinery at work now this
is giving me a full fully fleshed
erection
[Music]
it
okay oh it goes deep
[Music]
I want that thing to rub me it's getting
real nice oh it's a hell Mac uh-huh look
at that pizza oh it's too much no it's
too much the tomato sauce I can't oh
yeah yeah and stop yes now we're back
no yes yes yes oh oh I feel so satisfied
not the paper not the paper what are you
gonna do to that paper what what how is
he doing there
oh no I can't it's too much Danny you're
taking over I got it I need like five
minutes I'll be right back
[Music]
no well that was trying not to get
satisfied challenge did I satisfy you
this day leave a like if you I did and
I'll see you gross thanks this is so
[ __ ] dumb seriously stay awesome
brush
[Music]